I'm weary of Star Wars Rebels will it be
a worthy effort imbued with the
righteous power of the force will it be
an automatic dog sorry oh the new series
that just a beaut on disney XD seems to
have its heart in the right place it's
set before episode for a new home and
not in the middle of the prequels that
in itself is a good thing the makers of
rebels are taking great pains to assure
us that they want to go back to the
roots of what makes Star Wars great the
main characters are intriguing there's a
cowboy Jedi that could work plus there's
an alien and a droid that are based on
Ralph McQuarrie original concept art for
Chewbacca and r2d2 well here you pulled
it off promising this sounds yes but
I've been hurt too many times by
animated entries in the Star Wars saga
to get my hopes up some tunes have been
terrific those were steaming pile of
let's take a quick stroll through
the history of animated star wars on TV
and I'll show you what I mean the year
is 1978 and an animated sequence is the
only redeeming feature of the not so
special star wars holiday special this
thrilling one Wheeler introduce Boba
Fett to the franchise that almost makes
up for Carrie Fisher singing
enjoy we all share
almost the verdict on balance I declare
that this animation represents the light
side of the force let us move on to the
year nineteen eighty-five and witness
the witless pneus of two saturday
morning cartoon shows Star Wars droids
and Star Wars Ewoks I still don't know
why we have to carry the Jing Jing's
berries up to the guba bird's nest they
were made by the same animation studio
that brought us the Care Bears and
they're a shallow as a rain puddle on
Tatooine no we are always serious
missions we do not want to make snow
droid verdict these cartoons are
squarely on the top side they're as bad
as caravan of courage I think
that's right I said it now let's has
42,000 for him whoops I forgot to take
off the mask let's fast-forward to 2003
and behold season 1 of genndy
tartakovsky Clone Wars cartoons each
episode is just a few minutes long and
the time constraints meant that they had
to be boiled down to almost pure action
it's set during the prequels it did i
mention that i hate the prequels but
soppy romance stuff is kept to an
absolute minimum there's barely any
dialogue at all verdict light side all
the way onto 2005 when Lucas film
animation launched a series of Lego Star
Wars shorts for the Cartoon Network they
are full of ridiculous slapstick they
are completely non-canonical they are
transparently intended to sell high-end
toys and video games verdict I love them
light side then in 2008 the fully CG
version of clone wars to view it had
tons of cool battle scenes
but it also had uninvolved in store
yards long stretches of dull dialogue
and weird character designs that
couldn't convey emotion also they tried
to make size noodles dancehall sexy
verdict i'm calling it talk sided watch
some of you disagree with my opinion i
wish to you anyway i think some rules
emerge from this overview it's clear
that the best animated Star Wars shows
have lots of action not too much story
not too much cute zenus and they don't
take themselves too seriously if Star
Wars rebels follows those rules it
should be a worthy addition to the
franchise if it doesn't follow those
rules Oh for the record I think Star
Wars Phineas and Ferb and robot chicken
star wars are both terrific what bit of
star wars history would you like to see
an animated series set in I demand that
they make a cartoon version of the
planet of the who G of audio book let me
know you're picking the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel